bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ce aussi le golfe donc je me fais
marine je suis est doctorante en
sociologie et j'entame en fait deux le
chemin vers la thèse et du coup voilà je
pensais à faire un journal de thèse
poursuivre en fait l'évolution de mon
travail qui devrait mener dans cinq ans
peut-être à soutenir et à publier ma
thèse
voilà donc je voulais documenter sa
montre et en fait comment ça se passe
quel genre de décor le quotidien d'un
doctorant d'une autoroute et voilà alors
là on est en recul
on a en novembre 2020 enfin devant 2020
g j'ai été diplômé de master en décembre
entre temps j'ai construit pendant deux
ans un projet de thèse et j'ai travaillé
dans le privé c'est arrivé pendant plus
d'un an
et là j'ai terminé mon contrat et je
bénéficie d'une bourse d'étude qui va de
partir pendant cinq mois en mission pour
que la thèse sur le terrain donc je
m'envole vendredi à pau l'istanbul donc
dans
quelques jours sachant que nous sommes
dans un contexte un peu particulier
puisque nous sommes en plein confinement
due à la crise sanitaire
donc voilà je vais partir sans pouvoir
forcément voir mes proches et mes amis
un peu particulier mais je me sens très
chanceuse de pouvoir voyager jusque en
dehors des frontières et donc je pars
vers la turquie où je vais commencer à
travailler dès le début du mois de
décembre nous a jamais documentées aussi
bas mon départ que je connais déjà bien
que j'ai déjà travaillé
voilà alors là c'est quand même un peu
particulier les quelques jours avant
avant le départ en gros j'ai beaucoup de
choses administrative à mettre en place
donc pour le moment
en fait ça fait deux semaines que que
j'ai quitté mon emploi à temps plein et
c'est vrai que pour le moment j'ai pas
forcément ont pu commencer à travailler
sur la thèse en tant que tel parce que
déjà géorgie cas et je gère beaucoup
d'administratif donc massawa de
l'assurance aux billets d'avion à vos
questions de duels de visa
voilà plein de plein de choses à mettre
en place avant de avant de partir je
commence à rivaliser
et puis de valises ce sens que j'ai
besoin de la bibliographie notamment
donc c'est vrai que j'ai pas mal de
livres et puis des classeurs avec des
articles universitaires
je sais pas trop comment je vais faire
pour de travail et tout ça voilà lots
vas y on est à g - de départ et
aujourd'hui j'ai profité de la journée
pour remettre à fondre sur de
développement de socios de gosse
donc j'avais cette vidéo évidemment ça
existe déjà mais pour le moment là je
viens de créer le logo la bannière
youtube de créer le compte instagram
voilà donc je suis pas excité j'ai
tourné une vidéo
bref j'ai trop hâte que ça sorte savez
quelque chose que je ne maîtrise pas
forcément beaucoup niveau réseaux
sociaux et tout mais voilà c'est un
projet en tête depuis quelques mois je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup d'infos au
final sur comment se déroule une thèse
et de manière plus générale sur la
sociologie et enfin je vous que c'est un
domaine dans lequel il ya peu de
vulgarisation scientifique
alors qu'au final tout autour de nous et
sociologie et tout peut faire l'objet
d'une réflexion sociologique
donc voilà c'est ce que j'aimerais faire
avec avec cette chaîne youtube et le
pantin s'aggrave associés et et voilà je
suis en train de lancer tout ça et j'ai
pu voir que j'ai finalement je sautais
le pas j'espère que ça vous plaît
n'hésitez pas à aller checker mon compte
instagram et puis bah écoute et on verra
bien ce que ça peut évoluer dans les
semaines à venir
bon ça y est j'ai préparé mes affaires
pour pouvoir partir et je parle quand
même avec
valise trois valises et 1,16 j'espère
pour prendre des cours
quand je serai là bas c'est un mélange
d'excitation et puis un peu de stress
forcément de partir un stade serait
semée de voile a quitté la famille quoi
mais je suis trop contente parce que ça
fait des années que je travaille pour ce
moment tout simplement
du coup j'ai 3
ap
[Musique]
1 ça y est je suis arrivé à istanbul ça
fait deux jours que je suis installé je
suis arrivé donc pour le moment en dans
mon ancien coloc où j'ai fait mon
erasmus il a 5 ans donc c'est un
quartier que j'aime beaucoup c'est très
agréable de retrouver mes amis aussi
et puis demain je fais mon premier jour
à l'institut
donc j'ai vraiment hâte puisque ça va
être ma première vraie journée entre
guillemets de doctorante voilà c'est des
choses que je mets en place depuis très
très longtemps
la bourse que j'ai obtenus qui va
débuter demain
voilà j'ai fait les dossiers en descendu
j'ai envoyé mes les mon dossier en
décembre 2019
je vais obtenir en mars 2020 donc là de
me savoir qu'elle commence enfin c'est
c'est vraiment toi p voilà j'ai hâte de
commencer d'être dans un environnement
de chercheurs date à temps plein sur la
thèse voilà ça va être une super
expérience et j'ai trop hâte de vous
montrer aussi un peu mon quotidien à
istanbul qui est une ville magnifique
mais forcément je suis pas très objectif
voilà donc un petit peu comment ça s'est
passé pour moi je me dis que ce que tu
est aussi l'occasion de faire un point
sur ce que je fais exactement parce que
c'est pas forcément très clair je suis
doctorante en sociologie
j'ai deux directeurs de thèse donc un
directeur ou une directrice indien une
sociologue g je suis au tout début en
doctorat et je travaille en gros sur des
thématiques proches de l'agriculture de
la mondialisation de l'analyse de
l'implication des rapports sociaux
voilà en gros mais thématiques de
recherche je pense que je vous
présenterai une fois plus en détail mon
sujet de thèse
mais voilà je suis donc sur un projet
test je me taise qui implique un travail
de terrain en conséquent et donc ce
terrain et en turquie d'où la raison de
ma présence ici alors forcément
c'est un peu particulier de faire une
thèse en 2020 et encore j'estime que
l'espagne tout la plus impactée par la
chose à l'heure actuelle en turquie les
mesures sanitaires sont assez légères
ont pas rire la france il ya un
couvre-feu le week end mais il n'est pas
interdit par exemple de voyages xterra
pour autant c'est pas du tout dans mes
plans de le faire pour le moment et j'ai
de la chance parce que je suis plutôt
dans la phase en fait de recherche de
bibliographie de lecture de découverte
de nouvelles sources etc
donc c'est pas encore pour moi essentiel
d'être sûr d'être sur mon terrain direct
donc dans des espaces de production
agricole pour le moment je ne compte pas
du tout me rendre voilà pour tout
simplement ne pas mettre en danger des
personnes
et sinon pensez
voilà c'est clairement une période un
peu étrange je pense que ce qui est mal
plus manqué jusqu'à présent c'est quand
même le contact avec des collègues
chercheurs ou doctorants je pense que
c'est ça un petit peu le plus dur c'est
que c'est quand même un travail assez
solitaire la recherche et en même temps
c'est important de maintenir des liens
et forcément les conférences les
séminaires à distance bah c'est pas
pareil tout simplement on n'a pas cette
possibilité de pouvoir discuter un petit
peu enfin on va le dire après les
événements etc
et voilà je pense que ça qui va être
pour moi un petit peu le plus dur à
gérer dans un premier temps surtout
qu'il ya en plus de du numérique dieu
confinement et c'est pour moi une
distance géographique qui fait que je
vais beaucoup veut rapprocher des
équipes avec qui je travaillais en
turquie ce qui est super mais que je
suis en fait au début de ma thèse est
que je ne vais pas seulement rencontré
deux doctorants de chercheurs de mai
université d'origine
donc voilà c'est un petit peu la tuque
enfin pas que je m'inquiète mais en tout
cas j'ai réfléchi et je pense que
j'essaie de trouver aussi des moyens de
pouvoir échanger autrement mais mise à
part ça je suis super contente de
commencer de je me sens hyper chanceuse
d'avoir cette bourse mais ne viennent
pas forcément très longue et serra c'est
une chance énorme et de pouvoir
commencer par titre
sur ma thèse j'ai vraiment hâte d'être à
dimanche
ap
[Musique]
on
ça fait une semaine que je suis arrivé
en turquie que je suis à temps plein sur
mon doctorat
donc je suis toujours aussi contente ça
va super bien et je voulais un peu vous
expliquer ce que j'ai fait pendant cette
première semaine
donc je m'étais fait à un programme de
lecture notamment
je voulais absolument on va dire
profitez du tout début de doha pour un
plein en iran base et j'ai relu les
règles de la méthode sociologique de
turckheim
je pense que c'est assez important
pouvoir de revenir vraiment un plat de
retrait général de la sociaux et d'où
ces méthodes
parce que voilà je vais pas me lancer
que dans des lectures spécialisé sur mon
sujet donc j'ai relu dur calme et j'ai
eu aussi relu les critiques féministes
du rcam notamment du moins toutes les
critiques qui lui ont été faites du
point de vue du genre c'est une
thématique qui est essentiel dans dans
ma thèse est donc je voulais absolument
un booster pour lire à pas mal de
critiques de durkheim
j'en ai profité pour lire d'autres
textes de grands sociologues des
sociologues voix qui a qui sont un peu
un cas unique reste sociologique en
france et j'ai relu également l'art
critique du point de vue du genre et
après ça j'ai commencé à lire des
articles plus spécifique sur le sujet on
va dire sur des thématiques jeu du moins
est ce que je fais c'est que au fur et à
mesure que je lis je consigne tout je
consigne toutes mes lectures dans un
document qui est un peu mon programme de
lecture le but c'est que je donc rentré
ce document que je puisse ensuite
l'envoyer à peu près une fois par mois
ou toutes les deux semaines
ahmed directeur de thèse pour qu'ils
voient un peu où j'en suis niveau des
lectures et qui puisse me conseillez
peut-être voilà d'autres lectures des
choses qui m'aurait échappé
et puis moi ça me permet de déjà de
motiver de tenir le cap de voir en
avance et donc vous montrer rapidement
comment je m'organise
donc j'ai un document vous savez le
programme de lecture où je consigne en
fait par thématique
les tests que j'ai lu et ensuite j'ai
les fiches détaillées pour chaque texte
si je peux je surligne dans le pdf et
ensuite je récupère voilà les les
citations qui sont les plus
intéressantes pour moi et cetera voilà
encore une autre
du coup j'ai un document par lecture
plus un document un peu comme un
sommaire qui me permet de tout consigner
et pour montrer document 15 juillet lui
en fait au fur et à mesure de ma lecture
j'utilise voilà les options de
surlignage je peux faire des
commentaires directement ce qui voilà
donc avec différents types de surlignage
de souligner âge de commentaires etc
ça me permet de me trouver directement
dans ma lecture et ensuite d'extraire
plus facilement des extraits pour pour
mettre dans la fiche de lecture donc la
peur et mes sources à pour mes lectures
se trouve sur internet en accès sur
différentes plateformes
mais j'ai aussi emmener avec moi
quelques documents en version papier
donc je voulais rapidement voulait
montrer alors le premier ouvrage que
j'en ai c'est règles de la méthode
sociologique de turckheim
il ya deux ouvrages un peu de classique
on va dire de la sociologie que j'ai
emmené l'autre c'est une somme de
plusieurs textes
voilà ce qu'on appelle les classiques en
sociaux c'est-à-dire les auteurs qui
sont voilà elle parce que sanctuary zay
dans la sociologie à la française
je crois que dans celui ci on a joke à
hesmond à bourdieu
ces deux ouvrages un peu de classique si
j'ai besoin de revenir sur mes bases et
chauffe ça pas mal au début de la thèse
de relire des auteurs classiques
ça remet un peu en perspective et puis
ça montre aussi à tout le cheminement
que j'ai parcouru dans la réflexion
ensuite j'ai emmené peau noire masques
blancs de frantz fanon que je souhaitais
re lire également
il ya certains aspects de cet ouvrage
qui vont être utiles ou du moins qui
vont permettre de porter une réflexion
critique justement sur les grands
classiques de la sociologie
j'ai amené à deux éditions des cahiers
du cedref notamment celui ci équivalent
l'intersexualité à l'épreuve du terrain
et l'autre qui est un ouvrage en nom
collectif en anglais qui est
transformation of gender origines in
turkey donc deux thématiques qui voit
pas contre moi c'est des suffrages que
j'ai déjà lu mais qui sont tellement
saint trop que je me suis dit qu'il
valait peut-être que je les emmène
pourquoi les relais j'ai emmené avec moi
mon dictionnaire de la sociologie
c'est en soi c'est la documentation qui
est accessible en ligne
mais ce dictionnaire m'a accompagné
pendant une bonne personne des études et
je trouve qu'il peut toujours être utile
voilà je préfère l'avoir avec moi et
nous c'était du poids dans la malice
mais ça vaut le coup et j'ai amené avec
moi le rapport sur les inégalités en
france
c'est l'édition 2019 de l'observatoire
des inégalités
évidemment qui dit sociologie dit
observations des discriminations et des
inégalités notamment dans le milieu de
travail enfin de chômage de précarité
type de contrat et caetera et s'éteint
une ressource qui est extrêmement
intéressante
évidemment sa part de la france donc ça
monsieur particulier ma thèse parle pas
de ça mais c'est toujours intéressant
déjà en termes de citoyenneté loin
d'être au courant mais ce genre de
choses et puis du point de vue
sociologique c'est des méthodes
quantitatives
donc c'est toujours intéressant de voir
comment comment c'est fait d'ailleurs
vous pouvez acheter directement sur le
site de l'observatoire des inégalités
alors ça coûte pas très cher je crois
que celui-ci gt1 à feront et c'est
vraiment une source extrêmement
précieuse je trouve
il ya également je crois que le dernier
en date c'est le rapport sur les riches
en france avoir des informations très
intéressantes
ensuite j'ai emmené
c'est trois documents a4 même quatre
dossiers qui sont des impressions en
fait de textes que j'ai étudié pendant
mon master master de sociologie master 2
évidemment il n'y a pas tout mais c'est
vraiment les textes les plus importants
je faisais déjà travaillé mais il y en a
qui sont vraiment au coeur de ma
recherche et que je vais mobiliser pour
sûr donc c'est bien ce que je les ai
déjà à noter etc
je les ai emmenés sous cette forme c'est
pas la plus pratique
d'un point de vue poids et cetera met au
travail savoir ce qui me convient le
mieux donc des textes dotrice et auteur
sous qui sont des sociologues issus des
théories féministes et la dernière chose
que j'ai avec moi c'est ce classeur qui
est une version très allégée des textes
que j'avais imprimé en fait pendant mes
études en master parce que au bout d'un
moment tout simplement mes yeux je n'en
pouvais plus donc sur l'ordinateur donc
j'avais imprimer les textes sur lesquels
j'avais plus besoin de travailler et
j'ai choisi une toute petite partie de
ces textes que j'en ai un sur papier
déjà parce que je les ai travaillé aux
crayons etc directement et ensuite parce
que je sais que c'est des textes ou des
quatre joueurs à revenir pour ma thèse
donc autant les avoir déjà prêt par
exemple ils ont déjà été etc
je pourrais vous présenter certains de
ses textes peut-être à l'occasion
d'autres vidéos
donc mon classe à part ces lectures j'ai
travaillé à l'institut dans une bourse
ce qui m'a permis de rencontrer deux
doctorants doute chercheurs et forcément
d'échangés de prendre part à des projets
de séminaires de conférences
bon évidemment tout ce qui est surtout
pour l'instant mais voilà ça va aussi de
m'inscrire un petit peu dans la vie
académique de l'institut donc ça c'est
des choses qui commencent à peine à se
mettre en place
ça fait une semaine que je suis ici donc
voilà et aujourd'hui
je travaille depuis chez moi parce que
j'ai beaucoup de séminaires en ligne
aujourd'hui c'est du séminaire qui sont
sur doom des séminaires de université
d'origine
c'est l'aspect positif on va dire il
faut bien en trouver un de l'avant demi
c'est que même en étant en turquie je
peux suivre certains séminaires
alors après le problème c'est quand même
que la coulée sur internet je suis pas
au top mais voilà ça m'a permis de
suivre des séminaires qui sont relatifs
à des thématiques autant sur l'art
géographique dans laquelle je travaille
que sur les thématiques particulières
que j'aborde donc aujourd'hui j'ai un
autre séminaire un qui va d'ailleurs
bientôt commencer et j'ai également pas
mal de lectures à avancer donc voila mon
petit programme du jour
et au fait je vous aime vadim et donc
hier c'était j'ai lancé en fait le
compte instagram de sociologues hausse
donc voilà ça y est c'est parti
et puis j'ai hâte de vous sortir cette
vidéo pour lancer la chaîne youtube qui
va suivre
voilà le début de mon aventure sur les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]